en 2010 9 microsoft a surpris pas mal de
monde en sortant des produits qui
n'étaient pas du tout attendu alors on
attendait effectivement le
renouvellement de la surface prosys on a
eu la surface pro7 mais c'est pas tout
parce que vous avez également de la
performance avec un intel core de
deuxième génération i3 i5 i7 et nous ont
présenté plusieurs produits vraiment
séduisant il ya deux produits qui
sortiront fin 2020
on en reparlera dans quelques temps
surface nommé compagnie mais ils ont
également annoncé un produit qu'on
n'attendait pas particulièrement mais
qui au final va plutôt dans le bon sens
c'est la surface pro x c'est cette jolie
petite bête qui est dans cette jolie
petite boîte avec son clavier type cover
qui est là donc deux produits vendus
séparément deux produits qui sont
vraiment à ce que sur tout un produit
qui est extrêmement séduisant il ya
vraiment plein de choses super
intéressantes dans cette race pro x mais
aussi des points qui vont pas bien on va
donc aujourd'hui se faire un tour
complet de cette surface pro x je vais
vous dire pourquoi est-ce qu'il faut
l'acheter pourquoi le puck destiné pour
nous et pourquoi est-ce qu'il faut pas
l'acheter pourquoi est ce qu'elle est
parfaite pour vous avez pendant que vous
ça dépend de pas mal de choses vous
allez voir ça c'est simple mais avant
toute chose on retrouve en 2010
ans
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
oh
microsoft c'est une de ces marques qui
comme apple maîtrise la partie
logicielle maîtrise la partie matérielle
pour vous proposer un produit unique
c'est vraiment hyper intéressant et
hyper complet parce qu'on a un produit
qui est vraiment bien maîtrisé microsoft
reconnaît effectivement windows windows
7 a depuis très longtemps et la gamme
surface qui se développe petit à petit
avec un nouveau né cette année c'est la
surface boxeur qu'est ce que cette
surface prolixe propose de vraiment très
intéressant et bien en fait
la surface pro x c'est pas sa surface
pro x c'est ça ton âge et vous avez vu
que je vous le relève la surface pro x
c'est en fait une tablette c'est une
tablette dédiée à la mobilité à la
différence de la surface pro7 la surface
procède ce n'est pas ça la surface trop
7 c'est ça je fais les mêmes tours de
magie fut vraiment très fort note dans
la surface france est en fait c'est le 2
en 1 c'est l'ordinateur tablette que
vous pouvez emmener partout avec vous
qui est performant qui est vraiment bien
qui est très nomade mais pour lequel
vous faut une connexion wifi ou du
partage de connexion depuis votre
smartphone vous pouvez vous connecter à
internet
la différence que vous avec la surface
trop x c'est ce que qualcomm appelle les
all white and always connected des pc
qui sont toujours allumé des pc qui sont
toujours connectés parce que vous avez
une connexion 4g catch us à l'intérieur
alors en option bien évidemment il vous
faut un abonnement dédié
il faut soit nanosims soins à domicile
ça dépend bel et bien avant donc de
votre opérateur ça c'est cool parce que
ça montre en tout cas le futur ce
produit là et donc une évolution de ce
produit là sauf qu'en réalité c'est pas
réellement le cas
ce que j'aime déjà que cette surtaxe pro
x et design qui était vraiment améliorée
par rapport à la surface pour 7
on a débord qui sont beaucoup plus fin
sur la surface pro x par rapport à la
surface pro 7
on a un produit compact qui élégant
qu'on peut emmener partout avec soi qui
est vraiment format nomade et c'est
vraiment ce qui est très intéressant
avec cette surface producteurs vous
dirais ok sens là également sensiblement
la même façon avec la chanteuse procès
oui sauf que non malgré son châssis en
aluminium anodisé et ses 7 174 g cette
surface pro x n'est pas forcément celle
que vous croyez au quai alors est-ce que
je vous emmène là dedans c'est très
clair on sait qu'on a un ordinateur
tablette qui est destiné à la mobilité
que vous pouvez donc connectés partout
tout le temps facilement en
né avec vous c'est vraiment la donne de
ce produit n'est donc pas sur
l'ordinateur comme je le disais pas pour
l'instant dans ce procès mais au final
il ya un truc qui cloche et le truc qui
cloche c'est le trip
pourquoi parce que l'idéal est génial
l'idéal est fantastique le produit est
super bowl et finitions sont magnifiques
fedor des tout-petits bord c'est bien on
a l'impression que c'est une copie revue
améliorer la surface procède alors qu'en
fait c'est sa cousine
sauf que sa cousine et vous permet pas
de faire tout ce que vous voulez par
exemple qui peut être installée de
photoshop c'est un des problèmes
pourquoi parce que votre processeur est
basé sur une base arm c'est à dire en
gros sur up production de smartphones
l'ex microsoft a travaillé avec qualcomm
pour vous proposer son processeur
microsoft est ce qu un qui est inspiré
des processeurs snapdragon de qualcomm
alors effectivement ça marche ça marche
plutôt pas mal mais ça marchera pas pour
tous si vous voulez faire du photoshop
c'est pas possible il vous faudra des
vins sur l'aide de certains logiciels
donc si vous voulez l'acheter comme nos
ordinateurs tablettes que pouvait on est
partout il collectait partout avec vous
et bien c'est pas forcément le cas et ça
il faut le savoir
et ça c'est important ces points
positifs sont six ces points négatifs
alors avec cette tablette je me coupe de
pas mal de points qui au final sont
plutôt cruciaux si vous utiliser
photoshop
n'allez surtout pas sur ce produit allez
plutôt sur la surface pour cet effet
être un partage de connexion pour cette
zone vous connecte à internet ou aller
sur un wifi public avec un mauvais point
derrière
pourquoi pas ça ça vaut le coup mais
alors pourquoi acheter ce produit
pourquoi ce produit intéressant et bien
se produit il est intéressante dans
plusieurs cas de figure vous êtes un
commercial vous êtes souvent déplacement
vous avez besoin de faire du reporting
et vous connecter partout facilement
dans tous les cas de figure eh bien vous
avez une machine qui est vraiment fait
pour ça qui est adapté pour sa dont
celle adele s'est pas besoin de
l'allumer de l'étang dossier ça vous en
mettez pas vous appuyer sur votre petit
bouton on/off son côté et paf
elle démarre c'est trop
c'est facile vous êtes connectés en
permanence à internet pas besoin d'aller
faire un partage de coface vérifier
votre smartphone est un partage de
connexion vous n'avez pas utiliser la
connexion du smartphone
s'il a plus de batterie et bien cette
machine marchera toujours étroits
toujours de la compagnie ça c'est
vraiment le gros point fort pareil de la
même manière vous êtes sur un visage un
peu business eh bien vous avez office
avec office 365 devez vous connecter en
permanence internet pour utiliser votre
office avec toutes les améliorations que
vous avez et notamment grâce à ce petit
clavier est hostile et ça je vous
explique dans quelques instants pour l'
usage pont d'or sans cela c'est vraiment
bien si par contre vous êtes
professionnel et vous usez des
programmes bonbons et bien ce rêve
d'être un petit peu compliqué ça il faut
savoir si par contre vous voulez
regarder netflix youtube pour regarder
me suivre partout où vous voulez quand
vous voulez et bien vous pouvez le faire
ça c'est aussi très appréciable alors
soit vous aurait pas autant de
performances que les puces d'intel intel
core i5 i7 innove pourquoi pas mais
néanmoins ce quelque chose qui
fonctionne plutôt pas mal vous avez 8 ou
16 giga de ram
à vous de voir ce qui vous intéresse et
ce dont vous avez besoin et en termes de
stockage vous avez 128 256 512 giga ssv
bien évidemment donc à vous de faire
votre choix là dedans tout est ici vous
avez donc plusieurs possibilités vous
commencez 8 gigas de ram 128 go de
stockage à 1063 aurons je vous parle
juste de la surface qu'au xx sans
clavier sans style et ça il faut
vraiment savoir et c'est ce qui est très
important à prendre en compte lui il ya
de ram 256 go de stockage 1469 euros sem
plus de 150 6669 16 puis 72 1999 est un
outil qui est indispensable c'est celui
là celui là il est génial c'est un des
promus qui crée vraiment l'intérêt c'est
en face pro x allait bien mais sans ça
vous paraît vraiment une expérience vous
avez vraiment besoin de sap ça c'est le
clavier signature plus le stylet qui est
juste ici qui est incorporé deux banques
et ça c'est vraiment génial et ça ça
coûte 280 14 99
295 euros ça coûte quasiment 300 euros
ce qui fait que s'ils voulaient partir
sur une config allez on se prend une
config qui pourrait être pas mal
8 256 vous êtes quasiment à 1500 euros
pour acheter 300 euros c'est à 1800
euros se porter sur le cese 512 et à
2000 euros
c'est à 2300 euros tout ça pour avoir
une machine nomade pouvoir connecter
partout dans une machine avec laquelle
vous n'allez pas pouvoir tout faire et
vous n'êtes pas pouvoir installer tous
les programmes ça c'est vraiment un
super outil parce que vous le connecter
extrêmement facilement vous l'emmenez
porterez-vous pour l'utiliser en mode
tablette comme ça mais ce qui augmente
significativement l'expérience utiliser
le clavier qui a plusieurs fonctions
la première effectivement lorsque vous
le permet descendez quantité depuis
combien l'emmener partout avec vous ça
ne protège et ça c'est hyperimportant
plus et puis en alcantara ses douces et
agréables c'est vachement bien
mais ce qui fait la particularité de ce
clavier ce qu'a vraiment intéresser tout
le monde et je dirais lors de la
présentation c'est que lorsque vous
l'ouvrez comme ça et bien regardez vous
avez deux sit in et qui se veut juste
ici oui enfin dans une vraie belle
solution qui est très pratique pour
ranger son style et il est planqué juste
là et ça croyez moi ça change vraiment
que vous pouvez bien prendre votre style
et les récupérer extrêmement facilement
et lorsque vous leur mettez dedans et
bien c'est tout simplement rechargé pour
poser comme ça il disparaît ça c'est
vraiment génial
un stylet qui vous accompagnera partout
dans la prise de vos notes avec des
petits boutons ici sur le côté un petit
bouton en haut de l'appuyer vous êtes
pouvoir activer les captures d'écran un
stylet qui est vraiment un superbe outil
et que surtout cette fois ci on ne
risque pas de perdre
ça paraît tout mec comme ça mais c'est
vraiment génial en fait parce que ça
leur charge extrêmement facilement il
existe des tablettes vous venez le poser
sur le côté il est monté et il va se
charger cette manière sauf que lorsque
vous bouger un petit peu la table est
arrivé un moment wolski les tombes si
vous ne le voyez pas c'est tant pis pour
vous là ça fait vraiment mal et donc le
fait d'avoir cette petite encoche dans
votre clavier vous le prenez vous le
posez sale sharks s'est extrêmement bien
pensée la barre me concerne le style est
en lui-même marche bien pour naviguer
pour le bouger bon ça c'est un grand
classique une grande maîtrise de la part
de microsoft
vous pouvez venir griffonné très très
très facilement en dessus écrire ce que
vous voulez faire vos plus beaux dessins
de plus beau chez de leur pouvoir même
venir faire quelques morpion si vous
n'êtes pas très à l'aise et bien c'est
complètement possible vous pouvez très
facilement faire des captures d'écran en
cliquant ici
capture d'écran de la zone que vous
souhaitez je veux sélectionné ça je peux
récupérer mon image je peux venir la
notte je peux venir dessiner très
facilement dessus
on a donc indiqué très simple
d'utilisation et qui pour la
productivité en règle générale est
vraiment bien ça ça marche parfaitement
bien le clavier et hop il est
complètement rétro éclairé et surtout on
a un vrai confort lorsqu'on met à taper
dessus on en écran pixel 16 de 13 pouces
qui m'a franchement bien 2880 pas 1920
pixels à 267 pixels par pouce pour tout
ce qui est multimédia c'est vraiment
bien on a deux haut-parleurs de watts
qui marche vraiment bien maintenant ce
que je regrettais là dessus que la
différence de la surface pro 7 et bien
vous n'avez pas de prise jack non ici on
ne mange pas de casque avec une prise
jack is it où s'est clos par leurs deux
de watts vouloir avec un casque
bluetooth que cette loi reconnaît t
grâce au bluetooth 5.0 aura donc un
produit qui est vraiment cool pour toute
la partie multimédia
qu'en est il maintenant termes
d'autonomie parce que avoir un produit
qui est bien un produit qu'on prend des
parts ou un produit qui peut se
connecter très facilement partout c'est
bien mais s'il tient pas la charge
ça peut être un type en mettant est bien
là dessus microsoft nous annonce 13
heures de lecture de vidéos en local
c'est toujours compliqué à quantifier
parce que ça va dépendre de la
luminosité votre écran ça va dépendre de
pas mal de choses
moi je trouve à peu près allez on va
dire 8 heures d'autonomie
8h pose aucun problème vous emmenez avec
vous partout facilement vous donner huit
heures donc je trouve que la machine est
quand même endurante mais on n'arrive
pas exactement nous annonce microsoft je
connais pas le protocole de leur test je
sais pas comment est ce qu ils l'ont
fait peut-être que si vous baissez la
luminosité à fond que vous branchez rien
de vous déconnecter la 4g que vous êtes
déconnecté tout comme étaient juste des
vidéos en mode repeat que vous avez dans
votre machine
ça peut le faire pourquoi pas si elle
correspond à votre usage tant mieux mais
sinon je pense que huit heures c'est
vraiment là dessus qu'il faut tabler à
noter par contre que vous avez quand
même une charge qui rapide vous le
monter elle est quasiment 80 % nul
il tourne sur un windows dix familles
qui fonctionne merveilleusement bien on
retrouve à l'avant une caméra de 5
mégapixels qui permettra de
déverrouiller avec windows et l'eau
tandis qu'à l'arrière ha 10 mégapixels
qui filme en full hd
à noter également qu à la différence
d'une surface procède ici vous avez du
wifi 5 et pas de wifi 6 côté connectique
on va trouver un porte clavier type
en bas un port pour venir recharger deux
ports usb c mais ici pas d'usb c'est
dommage parce que l'usb en retour sur la
surface pro 7 mais pas face à ce point
allez savoir pourquoi
à la question est ce que cette surface
pro x est cool c'est un oui c'est un
grand oui elle extrêmement cool et très
bien réussi elle est très belle bien
profilée elle mange quand même
relativement bien sur base desquels on
va pas dans le même sport que jusqu'au
vous allez avoir sur une surface procède
sur un intel core mais ça me paraît
assez normal elle fait partie de cette
nouvelle génération de produits qui se
base sur la structure des possesseurs de
smartphones
donc on va pas avoir la même chose on va
pas chercher à une crise je pense que
c'est encore une typologie de produits
qui en train de se chercher sur le
marché qu'à pas forcément trouvé sa
clientèle qui est en train d'évoluer
c'est le début c'est très clairement le
début d'un nouveau type de la chine soit
le produit n'est pas encore suffisamment
aboutie il manque encore un petit peu de
performance soit le marché n'est pas
encore assez mature
c'est un produit qui peut
potentiellement vous est destinée si
vous une âge correspondent à ce que je
vous écris dans la vidéo en termes de
mobilité si vous êtes un nomade si vous
avez vraiment besoin de connecter
partout tout le temps vous voulez pas
forcément faire du partage de connexion
ou vous n'avez pas tout le temps accès à
du wifi par contre ce produit là moi je
trouve vraiment sympa j'aime beaucoup ce
qu'ils ont fait au niveau du clavier
c'est dommage
une fois de plus avec la gamme surface
que ce ne soit pas vendu avec à côté de
ça c'est aussi intéressant parce que si
vous n'avez pas besoin du clavier mais
que voulez juste une tablette nomades à
utiliser en tactile et bien ça vous
évite d'avoir le surcoût du clavier
beaucoup bon pourquoi pas ça c'est
effectivement c'est un produit que je
trouve par contre quand même
relativement cher par rapport à ce que
vous retrouver en face à la concurrence
qui en la tablette ou sur du deux en un
ça peut être un petit peu l'inconvénient
ce produit à côté de ça il est
extrêmement bien beauty sa chronique est
vraiment très très bon et que s'il vous
intéresse je ne peux que vous
recommander parce que je trouve vraiment
chouette a vous de me dire maintenant ce
que vous en pensez
comment vous ne trouvez cette surface
pour six ans commentaires mark et moi
tout ça est ce que
qui pourrait vous tenter est-ce que vous
avez déjà un produit de la gamme surface
et comment vous trouvez celui là par
rapport aux produits la gamme surface si
vous n'avez pas un peu des gammes
surface est ce que vous avez une
tablette est ce que vous avez par
exemple à un ipad pro vous pourriez
comparé par rapport à ce produit là
est-ce que vous avez un produit de chez
samsung galaxy sii ce que vous pourriez
comparer éventuellement se produit là et
surtout qu'est ce que vous pensez cette
nouvelle génération d'ordinateurs ou de
2 en un an loris connected always on
toujours allumée toujours connecté vous
marquez tout ça en bas en commentaire
ben nous on se retrouve dès demain pour
continuer à parler tech thomass à demain
[Musique]